hey guys how you doing this is just
going to be a short blog I'm actually
pretty sick today and I took a lot of
cold medicine so I want to go take a nap
but I don't take naps and instead I'm
just gonna go play video games but I've
got some important information I need to
tell you guys about the next charity
livestream it is confirmed we are doing
it we're selling these pajama pants on
September the 27th on September the 27th
and Bob and Wade are both gonna be there
I am very happy that they're both going
to be able to attend they don't have a
lot of free time and for them to be able
to fly out just for one day is awesome
so thank you to them and we're going to
be raising money for AbleGamers you can
find out more about them in the
description below they try to talk with
game developers to make sure that they
have disabled accessiblestl out for the
development of peripherals that people
who may not have limbs or even fingers
so that they can play games too it's
really awesome what they do so find out
in the description below more about what
they do so also I finally found out how
much we raised in the last charity
campaign with the tiny box Tim plushies
and t-shirts we raised just through
those alone ninety six thousand dollars
and on top of that we donated directly
about fifteen to sixteen thousand
dollars through the website and that's
astonishing so just thank you guys so
much for supporting everything that
we've done because that is the hundred
and twelve thousand dollars in one month
which is an amazing amount of money and
I will get that I think at the end of
this month and I'll be I'll be making a
check donation directly to the ALS
foundation as soon as I receive the
money I'll document it so that you guys
see it's totally legitimate everything
is through and through and just thank
you guys so much for raising such an
incredible amount of money for charity
you are absolutely awesome in them I'm
blown away by the amount of love and
support that you guys have shown for the
community and what we can do for these
charity campaigns I'm very sorry I do
not feel well right now but I'm just
trying to get through today so that I
can play video games and take naps and
drink your orange juice and then just go
to bed but seriously thank you guys once
again and I can't wait to do the next
one I know we're gonna do an amazing job
we're gonna continue to break goals and
records all over the place just raise so
much money and do so much good for the
world and that's awesome
anyway quickly finishing this up I did a
number of collapse recently I did the
speed runners collab if you didn't see
that already you probably did and it was
one of the funniest multiplayer sessions
we've ever done actually today I'm gonna
be playing a lot of speedrunners so if
you see markiplier in the game today
that is actually me unless it's a
copycat but it might be me if you don't
have speedrunners I'm literally going to
be playing all day so there's a link
down the description below where you can
get speedrunners
if you want to play with me today and
probably tomorrow because I know I got a
tournament thingy with a few other
youtubers tomorrow as well that I'm
gonna be practicing for and also I just
did a collab with Matthias in a video
was just released on his channel if you
guys know about the Disney song
challenge we did the Disney song
challenge to accrue Namit ah I can't do
this cuz my brain only caused one song
to eat Hakuna Matata
oh no do I lose the point nah and the
results may surprise you in this one eh
if anything I treats funnier than last
and yes I know my hair very fluffy I
spent an hour sitting in the shower just
sitting under the hot water cuz it felt
good and it gets really fluffy when I
shampoo and condition it and then sit in
hot water for a while and then sleep in
it it's mal that hurts my head remember
Saturday the 27th of this month the
charity livestream probably starting
again around 9:00 or 10:00 p.m. a.m.
Pacific Standard Time so use a website
converter to find out what timezone that
is for you I can't wait to see you guys
there it was absolutely awesome the last
time
oh there's Matthias right now he just
told me that the video is ready so thank
you guys again so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye oh and five nights at
Freddy's 2 is coming out in a few months